well after the surprise enjoyment of
return to Neverland a kind of good
Disney sequel I was suddenly reminded of
the bad Disney sequels with Jungle Book
- by no means an awful movie but
definitely a 100% completely pointless
one there is no reason to continue this
story there is no reason to see these
characters again the first one ended on
a perfect note Mowgli goes where he's
supposed to go and the animals go where
they're supposed to go so if you're
gonna do a sequel to this you should
make it really interesting he'll even
the original book had a sequel and it's
very very interesting in fact it's
downright depressing let's see how the
first film barely followed the book I
was expecting this one one neither
not only was I right I was really
disappointing Lee right Mowgli is still
a little boy and still in the man
village a family decides to take him in
he even manages to get a little bit of a
romantic acquaintance that is as much as
boys like girls at that age but he finds
the jungle is still calling him so one
day after getting in a fight with his
family he's suddenly out of nowhere
feels like he doesn't belong and decides
to run away and thus finds Baloo
Bagheera and all his animal friends
his girlfriend decides to chase after
him but little do they all know that
sheer Khan is back and once revenge from
Mowgli humiliating him in the past
will he slice into ribbons while they
sing bare necessities of minimum four
times oh how I wished as some of you
know I wasn't really the biggest fan of
the first jungle book that is to say it
was good it was fine I just really wish
there was a better rendition of the
story told but it's okay it's passable
so obviously in the sequel they try to
relive a bunch of scenes that you
remember from the first movie look
there's Karl
look there's the elephant's look there's
the vultures and that's really about it
the only things they're kinda new in
this is the opening and the ending the
opening where you see Mowgli in the man
village which honestly could have been
developed a lot more I think it's a
little too happy in the ending where
there's a climax in the ruins of an old
temple that wasn't for a bit but aside
from that it's literally just going from
character to character scene to scene
saying hey you remember this you
remember this yeah I do remember
this in fact I can just put on the first
movie to watch it they just go from one
distracting song to another distracting
song actually not even a different
distracting song most of the time is
just bare necessities the romance
between Mowgli and the girl isn't very
interesting the new characters they do
introduce just seem kind of pointless I
get the feeling this was intended for
little little kids and I guess as a
story for little little kids go it'll
entertain them for a bit but again it's
Disney and it's The Jungle Book don't
you think a little bit more time and
effort would go into the development of
this I mean on a technical level it's
not bad the animation is still really
nice especially on the human characters
the voice actors are good choices with
Haley Joel Osment mold Lee and Jung
Goodman as Baloo as well as Tony J
playing Shir khan and jim cummings as
caught these are all good replacements
but just makes you feel all the worse
that's being wasted on a story that just
has no reason to be nothing is
discovered nothing is really furthered
it just kind of goes back to what you
did in the first film and even then I
don't think I'm giving anything away
here he just kind of goes back to where
he belongs which yeah that's kind of
what happened the first film wasn't it
with Disney doing another live-action
remake of this story and it looks like
they're gonna stick to the animated film
once again it's such a shame to think we
will never see a movie version of this
book that's supposed to be like the book
I just never got outside of the Chuck
Jones short why we never got this
version on the big screen it's
interesting and kids would watch it and
adults would watch it it's the one time
a dark gritty reboot would be totally
welcomed but as someone who thought the
first film was OK at best this one just
left me completely empty and I think
most people forget it immediately after
they watch it I feel bad because there's
obviously a lot of work and talent that
went into making it but unless you do
something new or interesting I think I'm
gonna stay out of the jungle for a while